I've been to 24 countries over four
continents and I love Scandinavian
culture something about me as a
filmmaker I grew up in Abu Dhabi and I
study my a levels there and I went to
England for university with retention
this film I'm I've directed it's about a
CEO turning into a rat so the idea came
from mainly friends Kafka's
metamorphosis my background stems from
fine art so I used to use a lot of oils
in canvas and then this developed into
photography and film is moving image so
every frame should actually be like a
painting and is very difficult to
maintain this because this takes a lot
of time in creating shot lists we
designed every single shot in the film
so it was more to do with aesthetics and
it's not a feminist film the main
character actually was actually based on
myself and of course I'm not that
horrible but it was a part of me that I
wanted to destroy the best way to
express your negative traits is through
an art form and that's the only way to
have a release and of course they to get
rid of depression or anxiety or manic
psychosis which is what my future film
is about it's based on a tenday manic
psychosis episode
more on that later so we wanted to
explore in an authentic way like how
does it feel
becoming a rat and losing our beauty is
a huge theme in the film and so is
disfigurement so if you've combined
disfigurement with traditional beauty it
creates sort of duality in a picture and
I think that's quite important to
explore that's me I'm getting some hair
attached to my back my special-effects
makeup artist
yeah I'm just applying super hair this
is creepy focus on more about the animal
because at the end of the day I'm what
I'm playing a brat you know and it takes
up quite a lot just until we get that to
really realistically with the movement
and everything is a lot to focus on and
it helps to sort of not have to bother
and worry about for the mask or
something
falling off or herself like that Adam
Pearson has worked with Scarlett
Johansson in the film under the skin and
under the skin is directed by Jonathan
Glazer and Jonathan Glazer directed that
famous Guiness horse advertising
campaign so I wanted to find an actor
that's quite beautiful and I wanted them
to be together on set during the office
scene because it creates some sort of
duality
when opposites interact together you
kind of feel like a sense of completion
because a disfigured man with a
beautiful model you kind of feel like
they belong to each other and that's
what we tried to create in that specific
Ozzfest scene
also Fabian Belen is a method actor so
he practice in how to actually behave
like an animal on set we actually called
him by his character's name rather than
his real name
I think method acting is definitely
important when you want to actually
embody a character in a film another
interesting thing is we picked Fabian
Bolin as the main actor he's Swedish and
Brazilian and we picked him out of 200
applicants Swedish people tend to have
that sort of villain type of look and we
could see it in Bill skarsgård and we
could see it in that CTO wannabe guy in
mr. robot but Swedish people really fit
into the villains that I like well if
you want to check the film out it's in
the link in description and I'm still
connected to Dubai companies especially
3d animation and I'm also really into
creating music videos if you're a
musician or artist in Scandinavia or
anywhere in Europe I would love to work
with you and I've filmed five music
videos in Iceland and yeah I really
enjoy it
chase
[Music]